it's up to us to protect the city's sake
Charlotte you can tell ya
damn annoying question I was supposed to
save the bad guys just a few
very fast very furious hey everybody big
surprise they're already dropping early
promos for all the new seasons so we got
flash legends Supergirl arrow there's a
little bit of new footage from the first
episode of each mixed with some footage
from last season you actually see Barry
wearing that full future flash costume
that's what we're calling it now we're
gonna have to come up with another name
for it eventually we should probably
just call it the new flash costume and
then once we get to season five it'll
just be the flash costume there is a new
brand of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a DC TV related comment on the
video there's actually another promo
they released their hyping up the
release of vixen the animated series on
TV and they're gonna be doing a bunch of
DC TV flash air over stuff in
conjunction with that but because they
want to get people really hyped up for
that they're tying it to a bunch of new
flash season 4 arrow season 6 stuff this
Wednesday supposed to be vixen Tiffany
Smith hosts the team behind the CW's
most super shows for the two-hour
broadcast premiere I gotta run
to fix it special presentation this
Wednesday at 8/7 central on the CW so
they don't really say outright but we
might actually get more promos or at
least more information about what's
happening with each of the new seasons I
already did that episode 5 video we're
learning a little bit based on the
characters that they're casting katee
sackhoff gonna be a badass maybe if
they're doing iris West Bachelorette
episodes stuff they'll do Barry bachelor
parties stuff who knows that they can
get Stephen Amell to guest star it would
probably just be them sitting around
drinking beer watching movies but in the
promo the line iris West says we need to
protect our city is just from episode
one like they said a little bit about
how the team is kind of in shambles and
she and Wally are trying to do the
brother-sister team up thing that they
did during the flashpoint timeline at
the beginning of season 3 so Wally has
stepped up but he's still in the yellow
costume this other clip of Barry in the
future flash costume is either from the
very end of the episode because he's
only in that episode for a very brief
period and then Grant Gustin made it
sound like he's back for the entirety of
episode 2 there of course in the middle
of filming episode 5 right now they've
been posting a bunch of silly behind the
scenes stuff so I'll play these but it's
just them having fun
[Music]
of course they wait till tom felton has
left the show officially to start making
Harry Potter jokes again but for those
of you that are asking they didn't say
that Julian was never coming back they
just said he wouldn't be main cast and
tom Felton has been posting pictures of
himself traveling all over the world
while they've been filming these first
five episodes so if we hear about his
character it'll either be a flashback
scene from last season or it'll be
Kaitlyn just saying this is what
happened with him and then she's moved
forward with her life I know a lot of
you are still wondering what's going on
with her character is
she's some sort of in-between person
where she still has her powers but she
looks like Caitlyn that kind of sounds
like what they're doing like they're
really jumping her character forward so
there's a lot of character development
that you missed during this six-month
summer break but I think the key is in
this footage from the first episode
she's wearing that choker when she runs
in with Captain colds gun in the way
they have this deep neckline like I just
meant to draw attention to her neck so
even though it's not totally clear I
think that's a version of the pendant
that Julian gave her during season 3
that helps her keep her powers under
control Julian and I were talking about
your battery problem with your cuffs we
decided we eat it invest in an alternate
accessory voila
everytime you go outside solar energy
will reach a legit guys this means so
much to me thank you
[Music]
I don't want to automatically assume
that she took Julie and serum because
that was supposed to be an outright cure
and she says she didn't want that like
she didn't want to go back to being the
old version of Kaitlyn so whatever we're
seeing here is some sort of hybrid that
does not require danielle Panabaker to
go through like four hours of makeup
every single day but it is kind of weird
to see her going from this face here to
this face here like she is so happy at
the thought of getting buried back in
this moment and you think about what she
looked like at the height of thats
avatar arc last season and it's just
night and day so they'll have to be some
sort of explainer like when we picked up
in season 2
Kaitlyn had been working at mercury labs
we learned a little bit about what she'd
been up to but you don't really see all
that stuff happened before she came back
to STAR Labs so this is what it looks
like inside mercury labs secured here is
way better than it was at STAR Labs well
with people walking in and out of the
cortex all the time thanks ESCO so just
expecting similar treatment this season
but let me know in the comments what are
you guys most excited about they might
drop a couple more promos like this the
next couple weeks where they Jam stuff
together before they start dropping more
singular promos for each of the
different episodes but if you haven't
watched the Vixen series and you want to
go back I've already done videos for
that because it happened a couple years
ago like there's a vixen playlist on my
channel but it wound up only being about
a half an hour worth of content so I'm
not gonna do new videos for vixen stuff
just because it's old episodes but when
they say it's a two-hour premiere what
they did is they jammed season 1 and
season two of vixen together that's
about an hour in the other hour of
content is like the TV ads that they
splice into that along with all the
other interviews they do with the
arrowverse producers and directors and
actors so half of it'll be vixx and
stuff the other half will be them hyping
up the new seasons but congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner joking
Jackson please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here for brand new
flash and you can click here for brand
new Game of Thrones thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight